hello hello what's your name Celine
hello Celine hi jack what story have you
got for us well this is my second visit
to the red chair actually oh I was here
eight years ago right and I told a story
that I thought was really good about
when I was living in France and
something happened with my daughter
however a certain guest on the sofa that
night really did not like my story and
he was rather rude he actually said is
that the best story she could come up
with
who does she bloody think she is funnily
enough my daughter met this person at a
nightclub recently oh my god it's me
[Applause]
[Music]
walking I sent you a message didn't I
you did apologize I know I'm so sorry
that was so cool
hello hello hi what's your name Jess
Jess lovely and what do you do Jess I'm
a PA a PA to to someone in finance okay
and when you all go back to work on
Tuesday why'd you be fired after telling
the story quite possible okay let's go
for it
so I used to live with my best friend
and what we had to film night one nights
where we get in bed in our matching
onesies and we were actually watching
pitch perfect I rebel we were we like
watching it drinking our wine and about
halfway through we ran out of wine so I
leant forward to pause the film on my
laptop and what my friend what my friend
didn't know is I don't wear any
underwear under my onesie I just had
nothing on underneath and what neither
of us knew is I had a hole in the crotch
of my onesie
so I leant towards pause the film and at
the same time my friend who wasn't
really paying attention she went to poke
me in the bum finger and the hole in my
onesie and a part of me she shouldn't be
touching all
[Applause]
we just sat there frozen and then we
didn't talk for about a month
okay sorry David we've got distract me
go with your story and so back when I
started at University I met this lovely
girl and spent a lovely evening with her
and in the morning she woke me up and
threw me out and I was half asleep half
naked and the next week
I walked into my lecture theatre meeting
these new people for the first time and
this guy was telling a story about how
he had these new trainers of this guy
who'd slept with his girlfriend I had to
sit in that lecture theatre with that
gentleman for four years and he's still
got my trainer
in the World War II or David
- yeah she stole shoes out leaving his
shoes and the guy was wearing his shoes
yes Wow is that good
hello hello hi what's your name Sarah
Sarah and what do you do sorry I'm a
midwife a midwife David Tennant method
oil tea card I said good story Midwife l
have a good story off you go with your
story unfortunately it's not about being
a midwife it implicates my boyfriend so
and my boyfriend is lives in Scotland so
I was over here visiting him and it's
the second time I'd met his family what
since we've been together so weird like
Dhruv to a rural part of Scotland and we
parked and rock out of the car to go for
a walk and there was a playground there
so Sam ran to a seesaw and I went to the
other side he's a lot bigger than I am
so when he jumped on I went up and the
first time I got a little bit of air and
I pulled myself down and I laughed and
because I laughed the next time he did
it he catapulted me into the air like 10
to 12 feet in the air and I landed teeth
first on a metal bar I smashed three of
my teeth in and yeah I was beside the
bond it's like I'm fine I'm fine
all of my teeth are in the wrong place
but I'm fine I was definitely not fine
and um yes I would have introduction
named are you still with that [ __ ] not
unfortunately yes I definitely am he's
the loveliest so and plus I've got the
best you know thing of over him so yeah
and used to come I think I'm your new
cheese our lovely totem is still dead
and there's still truth shattered into
my lips so you busy you must walk you
have to walk
hi okay are you from Australia New
Zealand I am from Australia okay do you
know that this was G call Sarah yeah I
do okay
are you related to her in some way yes
she's my twin sister both my sisters -
hmm hey both my sisters as well
Australian and are you traveling with
your sister or what's the story no I
live in London and she's visiting oh
okay
and how are your teeth my teeth are fine
yeah good I know okay I'll be the story
so this is a story about my cousin so
visiting them in Adelaide and as we were
flying they met us at the airport to see
yourself and my cousin was four years
old and as he was watching our plane
take off he put his hands on his hips
looked up the sky and said I can't wait
till I'm old enough to ride a virgin
hello hi what's your name Stephanie
Stephanie lovely and what do you do
Stephanie I work in marketing marketing
and that where do you got from here I'm
from Chicago but you do live here now
yes I live in London okay fair enough
okay off you go with the short so my
stories actually about storms eat so
just recently
okay I'm poor just give me give me a
look storms in anytime okay keep going
so just recently my fiancee and I were
moving to London and we had gotten up so
early to try and beat the traffic
but of course while we were headed there
we hit horrible traffic at this
roundabout and I was telling my fiancee
make sure you keep up with the cars in
front of you because we were late to
pick up the couch and we were finally
about to get out of this traffic once we
were stuck in it for ages
and out of the corner of my eye I see
this car just slowly inching forward
trying to get in front of us and all of
a sudden my fiancee slams on his brakes
and I look over and all I see is storms
II popping his head out of the passenger
window giving us a cheeky wave it was so
excited he let him through the light and
we ended up missing it and not being
able to pick up our couch
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you